In a game of egg
Russian roulette.
This one's hard.
In a game
of Facebreakers.
[cheers and applause]
It's time to play
Mind Link.
(all)
Oh!
All right, this is a phrase.
It's a phrase.
Hit me again.
Oh!
Shoot.
(both)
♪ Down, down, baby ♪
♪ Down by the roller coaster ♪
[upbeat music]
[cheers and applause]
- ♪ Yeah ♪
- ♪ Doo-doo-doo ♪
♪ Came in like
a wrecking ball ♪
♪ I never hit so hard in love ♪
Is there anything funnier
than a celebrity
pretending to sing a song
that a different celebrity
originally sang?
Yes, many things.
You sheep would watch paint dry
if it was called
Celebrity Paint Drying.
Recently, a writer for Conan
got in some hot water
for [bleep]
on other late night shows
that rely on celebrity cameos
and games instead of jokes.
Conan, of course, apologized
and told him to shut up.
He deleted the tweets,
and all was forgiven.
If any of my writers did that,
I'd commend them for being
100% right for a change.
Then I'd fire them
just to show people
I'm in control.
I never appear on talk shows
because I don't want
to pretend to enjoy
goofing around
with Jimmy Fallon.
[giggles]
Ah, you're right.
I am awesome.
But if playing games
with celebrities
is all it takes
to entertain you,
I am happy to phone it in.
(male announcer)
From the lazy producers
of Lip Sync Battle,
it's yet another cynical,
unoriginal Hollywood cash grab.
Tosh's Hide & Seek
With the Stars
on Spike because no one can find
that channel either.
Hiding on Tosh tonight,
she's been called the
Anne Hathaway of her generation.
Give it up for Anna Kendrick.
[cheers and applause]
He'll love playing this game
because he's
an intellectual child.
It's Keanu Reeves.
[cheers and applause]
She's the girl next door
who's a little bit slutty
and could use some good
publicity.
It's famous person
Jennifer Lawrence.
[cheers and applause]
(Daniel)
99 Mississippi.
100 Mississippi.
Ready or not, here I come.
Oh, she's not here.
Let me check the cloud.
There you are.
(all)
Ooh!
Where are you, Keanu?
You quiet, moody,
1/4 Chinese sexpot.
[all clamoring]
Anna Kendrick,
I can't hear or see you,
but you're still annoying me
somehow.
[uproarious laughter]
Fingers crossed
we never find Anna Kendrick.
Tune in next week.
Alec Baldwin will be
on Celebrity Silent Game.
[laughter]
[laughs]
I could watch him do anything.